mesdames messieurs bonsoir l'ex maire de
laval gilles vaillancourt accusés de
gangstérisme pourra aller passer
quelques semaines s'il le veut en
floride
il avait pourtant dû remettre son
passeport à la sûreté du québec après
avoir été arrêté au mois de mai dernier
on va en discuter à l'instant avec
isabel richer isabelle gilles
vaillancourt s'est adressé au tribunal
et le juge a dit oui à sa demande
c'est vrai et c'est parce qu'il est
présumé innocent et christian c'est vrai
qu'il va passer les accusations très
graves gangstérisme on le dit frau de
corruption mais il n'est pas condamné il
n'y a pas subi son procès encore et bien
que la couronne soupçonne qu'il était
vraiment la tête dirigeante de toute
cette affaire il n'ya pas encore subi
son procès et en plus on ne le considère
pas comme étant quelqu'un de dangereux
leye les crimes de fraudes c'est pas
comme des crimes contre la personne donc
il va pouvoir voyager mais on décide
d'encadrer cette demande là c'est à dire
qui pourra partir seulement deux
semaines soit en mars soit en avril on
les oblige à résider dans sa maison en
floride
il devra donner son itinéraire il devra
prévenir la sûreté du québec une semaine
avant de partir mais évidemment c'est
pas dit que les états unis vont
l'accepter parce que ils ont le
privilège de d'accueillir qu'ils veulent
sur leur territoire on verra bien on
peut écouter le porte parole du du
directeur des poursuites criminelles et
pénales faut comprendre que les
conditions de remise en liberté ils sont
sont là pour garantir la présence dans
la cour entre autres et est donc tout
individu qui est présumé innocent
certaines ça peut avoir certaines
restrictions à sa liberté mais en même
temps les cons sont remises en liberté
ne sont point de punition dans un
dossier où isabelle d'autres accusés
dans cette affaire ont obtenu la même
perdition c'est vrai notamment l'ancien
directeur général de la ville claude
asselin qui a eu le même privilège
et puis c'est déjà arrivé dans d'autres
dossiers ce ça arrive régulièrement
qu'on permette à des accusés la de de
quitter le pays évidemment les autorités
à cette s'assurer qu'ils ont des liens
assez forts ici des attaches pour
s'assurer qu'ils vont revenir c'est
arrivé aussi à michael applebaum qui
avait prévu un voyage avant d'être
arrêtés ils avaient réussi à récupérer
son passeport mais il y avait annulé son
voyage alors ça arrive dans certains cas
merci beaucoup aux blues en privé on va
voir